as how are you doing I'm great shaking
my very cool I'm so excited to be here
it's so much fun to talk to people we've
actually seen episodes at the show now
it's gay yeah I was gonna say what a
giant show it's it's so big yeah I'm
wondering how you squared that away when
you first started how this what was the
Nugget of the idea that became adapting
this massive thing into a show you know
I mean the Nugget of the idea I mean
obviously I am dealing with a super
popular franchise already we were based
on the books there's also very popular
video games a couple people have heard
of you know so there's a lot of material
out there I connected with a story
because of the three main characters
Carl Jennifer and Siri and really for me
the most important thing was making sure
that every episode came back to you to
one of them to building them up as these
fully fleshed out complicated layered
characters and eventually bringing those
characters together and allowing them to
start to intersect and so it's fun it's
been fun to add in all the bells and
whistles of fantasy that people expect
so you get lots of monsters and lots of
magic and there's blood and there's sex
there's everything but also there are
these characters and it's their story in
their journeys and I think that's what
people are actually going to continue
tuning in to see I want to talk about
the music on this show especially going
to your Witcher because that is a
genuinely great song all right it's been
stuck I watched the first five episodes
last night and I saw something we had
yes like 24 hours straight I'm wondering
how that started on the page and how
that then you and everyone involved
production made that song happen um so
hilarious it's been stuck in your head
for 24 hours because I just paid that oh
he about 72 total um from experiment
accident it's one of those things that I
was just saying like when I'm on a mixed
age and I heard it laid into the show
for the first time it was stuck in my
head for days um we go with a really
sort of organic approach with our music
which is the writers actually write the
lyrics to their songs because to me the
important thing about putting music in a
story is it needs to reinforce the story
that we're telling so the writers
themselves would write the lyrics if
we were having a scare song in the
episode and then our amazing composers
Sonia Bela Sava and Jonah Austin le they
came in and worked on the composition
behind it in the orchestration behind it
and oftentimes they would send me
several different versions sometimes you
know I would send things back with notes
but it's incredible because what I love
is letting people do their jobs really
well with the skill set that I don't
have I don't know much about music so I
should never compose anything nor should
I put all of my ideas on what is being
composed and there would be times that
Sonia and Jonah would come back to me
and lay in a comedic song where I
thought a super serious artist one
should go and to me it's the music is
one of the things that really sets the
tone of the entire piece and I think
they've done an incredible job so when
you have a character like like girl
who's you know notably stoic people
comment on it it's just sort of the
witches thing I'm wondering how in the
writing process you what steps you take
to still make him relatable when he so
much of the time is this solid brick
wall being a being um it's a great
question because in fact in the books
girl talks a lot he espouses everything
you learn everything that's going on in
his brain he is telling a character
named Biola a story the entire you know
the entire first book the last wish um
he talks a lot so the very first script
that I wrote girl talked a lot and then
I met Henry and when Henry and I started
collaborating on this character at first
he was just doing all the lines as they
were scripted and then we were on set
together and we started to talk about
and we realized that we have an asset
that none of the other sort of mediums
have when when adapting to Witcher which
is we have actors who have faces that
can make great expressions or grunts or
you know looks of to the side it is it
was a really fun experiment to sort of
start pulling back on Geralt and to see
just how much could be communicated with
very few words and it's one of the
things that I think Henry is best at are
you aware of how popular and widespread
the image from The Witcher game of
in the bathtub is and I'm wondering how
important it was to get that into the
show which would she did um it's uh yes
yes I am a member of the human
population so I've seen that mean um you
know what was fun for us obviously we're
not adapting the video games video games
are an adaptation of the books too so
they're pulling from the same source
material we are but I also know
especially being an American myself that
a lot of especially American audiences
are mostly familiar with the games they
didn't even know that books existed so
they are part of our hopeful fanbase and
it's just a little wink and a nod to
them to tell them that we see them too
and something I love in any show is when
you have monsters with a practical
nature to them
yes I'm wondering how important in the
planning process everyone was in getting
that aspect into the show it's so
important because to me um you know
there are so many things that can be
gratuitous and television I think you
can have her to it as violence you can
have coitus nudity and oddly you could
have gratuitous monsters which means we
could suck up all of our CGI budget or
our prosthetics budget putting monsters
in every scene but then at some point
you're gonna get really bored of Geralt
killing them because they mean nothing
it was really fun to dig into the
monsters that are in the books that have
these incredible backstories and have
these incredible drives and put
Carrollton place where he's discovering
it with the audience this trigga was
absolutely my favorite monster to
develop and bring into the series
because it's when you're brought into
the story you hear about this monster
that is absolutely decimating a town and
killing everyone and it seems really
simple Geralt needs to go in and kill
the monster and I loved flipping that on
its head and seeing when he meets the
Strega and he learns that it's actually
a cursed little girl and he makes the
decision to try save her instead I think
it's a really unexpected way to tell the
stories those are my favorite monsters
that have I don't know their own
personalities and their own points of
view sure so this is this is going to
touch a little bit on it's getting a
little bit in display so I will not
share this question until after premiere
I wondering when how you decided when
you decide how you're going to tell the
story the way it's broken up into
different time periods because I don't
something that is even revealed in the
marketing I think the fact that this is
this is taking place across different
time lines is really interesting so
sorry I'm wondering how that decision
camera um we have purposely held that
back in marketing um although any fan
will tell you that as they started to
piece together what stories we were
telling and they can say well series not
alive in those stories which is the
reason that we did it it started from a
very practical place which is I knew
that there were short stories from the
last wish that I wanted to adapt but
we're missing one of our main characters
sometimes both of our main characters in
those stories and it was equally
important for me to introduce ciri
Indiana for much earlier in a series
they're really intriguing characters and
they they are as much a part of Geralt
journey as Geralt himself is and so I
wanted to build them up and sort of
fully form them give them their own
independent desires and their own
independent journeys before they met him
so I really had a conductor about how do
I do both of these things and I watched
Dunkirk the movie and I had read an
interview with Christopher Nolan after I
saw it and he was talking about his
timelines because there are also three
timelines in that movie and each one of
them is you know one of them's just a
day one of them's a week one of those a
month they're all different times but he
was when he was talking about making the
movie he said if I told them in order
you would think that the mission that
took a day was the least important part
of the process when in fact it was just
as important as the one that took a
month and I no kidding had one of those
moments where I hopped out of the shower
and I said to my husband could I do that
in the show and he was like it was gonna
be difficult and I was like that's fine
I'm up for the challenge but can we do
it and it was the first time that I felt
oh my god I know how I want to tell
these stories and to the credit of the
writers room when they came along I was
like here's it's really confusing or it
could be really confusing and they were
all in on making it work amazing and one
last thing I'm case how what process you
are in season two and how deep into into
that you are because I think you'd start
filming early next year we'll start
filming in 2020 Wow saying that word is
weird only like a week away yeah so say
okay we will not stop start filming in a
week um but you know we are at the point
where we know the stories we want to
tell we're in the process
of telling them but all the pieces are
just starting to come together you know
for now I'm just so excited I've been
living with this project for over two
years so I'm so excited for the rest of
the world to finally see it